cinéma avec la sortie sur les écrans de
malina de giuseppe tornatore est primé
au festival du film romantique de
cabourg la beauté spectaculaire de
monica bellucci dans ce film qui se
déroule en sicile durant la seconde
guerre mondiale monica bellucci sera
cléopâtre dans le prochain film d'alain
chabat et tournera dans matrix de monica
bellucci qui est notre invité devenu la
coqueluche des réalisateurs marino
jouant et patrick voir
charme envoûtant sensualité dévastatrice
pazzapa film après film
monica bellucci bombe italienne de 33
ans ne laisse personne de marbre quand
elle s'installe dans un film ou dans la
rue les esprits s'enflamment dans le
film de giuseppe tornatore est lé malina
jeune femme solitaire livrée à elle même
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
victime de convoitises et de jalousie
causée par une trop grande beauté
la belle vient de la mode et lorsqu'on
est un modèle tout le monde sait comme
il est peu évidente d'occuper
intelligemment le grand écran virages
négociés en douceur en 92 coppola ont
fait une vampire à couper le souffle
quatre ans plus tard à césar pour
l'appartement de gilles nîmes où elle y
rencontre vincent cassel aujourd'hui son
mari à la ville comme une provocation
jan kounen en fait une tueuse sourde et
muette dans dobermann tendre lesbiennes
dans mauvais genre ouvrière dans
embrasse moi elle reprend avec talent le
rôle de romy schneider dans le remake
américain de garde à vue les cinéastes
ont déjà compris qu'elle n'est pas
seulement belle premier cas c'est
quelqu'un mais bien de nature
c'est quelqu'un qui vous met à l'aise
c'est important quand on rencontre
quelqu'un comme monica d'être mis à
l'aise enfin et c'est quelqu'un avec qui
se serait facilement une complicité même
complicité avec christophe gans
réalisateur du pacte des loups
monica bellucci incarna sulfureuse ange
noir
elle dit que ce qui rend une femme
désirable
ce n'est pas le regard de millions de
personnes mais celui de l'homme qu'elle
aime dans malina c'est un adolescent qui
sont sous son charme à l'italienne
comme toutes celles qui l'ont fait rêver
lorsqu'elle était enfant sophia loren
gina lollobrigida claudia cardinale où
silvana mangano